[Musique]
vous avez vu les résultats des oscars
parasite le film sud-coréen qui a
remporté le film du meilleur oscars et 4
4 oscars en tout c'est incroyable c'est
super parce que ce film là nous on adore
donc parasites en version noir et blanc
au cinéma le grenier à sel c'est bientôt
nous avons aussi un événement japonais a
dont vous voulez vous parler c'est un
fils il ya un film qui s'appelle dans un
jardin qu'on croyait à conduire et
éternelle c'est l'histoire d'une de deux
jeunes filles qui vont découvrir là
à la cérémonie traditionnelle du thé
c'est l'occasion pour nous de faire
dormir avec des dégustations dégustation
de thé évidemment puisque c'est le sujet
du film mais aussi ce sera donc il y
aura un thé gratuit et il y aura aussi
des pâtisseries et des mini benneteau à
acheter donc ce sera ça la toute fin des
vacances ce dimanche 23 février à 17h15
nous avons un autre événement dont on
vous voulez vous parler au mois de mars
il ya la journée du des droits des
femmes et nous le samedi 7 mars à 15
heures où nous diffuserons le film human
qui est coréalisé par la nature arthus
bertrand
j'en profite pour vous dire que vous
pouvez réserver vos places directement
sur notre site
nous avons une billeterie en ligne et
nous avons une innovation aussi un
système s'appelle tous évoquent ce qui
permet aux malentendants mal voyants
sourds non voyants de venir profiter du
cinéma comme comme tout comme nous tous
si vous voulez en savoir plus vous
regardez sur notre site où vous demander
à l'accueil au cinéma
[Musique]